[Musique]
il
bonjour nous avons aujourd'hui pour ce
vip
trois invités que je vais donc vous
présenter docteur véronique mal un bon
jour laurence du pain bonjour v et
charles-edouard de surville bonjour
alors vous êtes là tous les trois pour
un projet qui vous réunit dont vous êtes
les acteurs entre autres est à
l'initiative de ce projet il ya une
association qui s'appelle art
convergence qui existe depuis 2013 dont
laurence du paraissait présente est la
présidente est une des cofondatrices
j'imagine ont rien fait elle s'est créée
en 2003 avec véronique mal a donc qui
met les dents au psychiatre ferrara
exactement et elle permet en fait à des
personnes qui souffrent de maladies
psychiques de travailler avec des
artistes expérimentés et reconnus et
dans ce cadre là on a réalisé déjà
différents projets et là on est là pour
vous parler plus particulièrement de
celui qui se tient à saint germain en
laye en ce moment voilà et y donc c'est
une exposition qui part d'un concept de
voilà on voit l'affiché qui sur les
écrans jardin de mémoire ça a lieu dans
les jardins du domaine nationale de
saint germain en laye donc c'est un
concept que vous allez peut-être nous
expliquait laurent encore à vous allez
il est né du lieu déjà du site les
jardins de saint germain en laye qui
sont à la fois le jardin anglais le
jardin français qu'ils font quand même
44 hectares au pied du château et on a
eu la chance de
killer multone le directeur du château
nous propose d'investir le lieu à l'été
2010 8 quand on est allé le voir avec
leur uniquement là il ya quelques mois
et donc on est parti de ça pour le
proposer un certain nombre depuis
toujours et surtout des artistes qui
nous ont accompagnés dans l'idée du
projet donc on est partis déjà relancé
le terme de la mémoire parce que la
mémoire en temps
2018 mémoire c'est le château est né
louis xiv c'est aussi une problématique
on retrouve en psychiatrie donc on est
parti de ce concept là et puis c puis de
là ça a démarré nous laissait donc on
peut parler je crois de parcours
sensoriel il ya différentes oeuvres
différents artistes qui ont qui ont créé
à l'occasion exprès pour le lieu c'est
sa chair l'histoire de surville in situ
l'objectif était vraiment de s'inscrire
dans un parcours dans le dans le jardin
ouais effectivement c'est un jardin
extraordinaire qui à la fois un jardin
français
donc techniquement c'est une vision de
la nature très très ordonnée mais très
maîtrisé assez différent de ce qu'on
peut trouver dans la dans la réalité et
puis un jardin anglais un peu plus le
contraire tardif exactement mais tout
aussi fabriqué tout aussi artificielle
mais qui donne au contact c'est cette
impression d'être faussement naturel et
qui donne deux sensations très
différentes et et puis une terrasse avec
une vue extraordinaire qu'on essayait
aussi de des perspectives donc vraiment
un cadre exceptionnel
d'accord nous a tous inspiré et donc on
a à tour de rôle défini des lieux
d'intervention très bien ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que cette exposition elle
dure depuis le début du mois de juillet
les inscrits dans le temps elle tient
compte de l'évolution de la nature et de
la pérennité des oeuvres on en reparlera
tout à l'heure je pense au piano et aux
abeilles par exemple et qu'elle dure
jusqu'en octobre
et donc on peut encore aller la voir là
au contraire
jusqu'en octobre voilà vous docteur
véronique malade on vous êtes 6 kg a
tous travaillé principalement ou centre
hospitalier de plaisir d'accord et est
leur racontez moi qu'elle est pourquoi
cet engagement dans cette association
qu'est ce que ça vous
qu'est ce qui vous motive alors les
personnes souffrant de maladies
psychiques
finalement on
souvent une création artistique qui est
reste assez préservé malgré la maladie
et
là où l'expression artistique permet
aussi et surtout la déstigmatisation
c'est à dire ça permet à ces personnes
d'exister en tant que voix la personne
que faisant une oeuvre artistique
participants à quelque chose de
collectif sans être étiqueté malades
d'accord donc pour vous c'est un énorme
bénéfice dont le choix et dans la
reconnaissance sociale
deux personnes qui peuvent exister
autrement qu'en tant que malade
oui ça va avec j'imagine voilà il est
l'heureuse vous avez envie de quelque
chose là oui c'est un projet est parti
de l'idée de la co-création qui était un
peu particulier parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas toujours simple de faire
travailler des artistes oui au sein des
hôpitaux parce que ça a été ça en fait
là alors je me consacre aux traitements
on est parti donc d'un parcours
artistique et sonore qui a été imaginée
qui a été l'architecturé du projet par
eric lemaire et charles-edouard de
survie quittant pas d'enjeu beaucoup de
temps en temps mais voilà ce qui sont
les deux artistes autre directeur
artistique on pourrait les intéristes du
projet qui ont l air vallier d'emblée
avec les équipes du château donc sur le
lieu sur le site est bloqué du château
ces jardiniers ni en chef c'est
annabelle polignac qui s'occupe des deux
touches de tout ce qui est exposition au
musée qui nous a beaucoup aidés beaucoup
et charles-edouard particulièrement mais
c'est vrai que les terres une
coopération qui était très très
intéressant et c'est vrai qu'on a
travaillé avec des hôpitaux de jour en
psychiatrie qui chacun avec des
problématiques et des sites différents
parce qu'entre malines est bien terrien
cet hôpital de jour donc versailles
rambouillet saint germain a et rap
on leur a dit vous allez travailler sur
7 1 vous commandez maintenant on leur a
dit voilà on vous allez travailler sur
le projet donc le même concept qu'on
avait donné à eric lemaire et à charles
édouard au début on va avec d'autres
artistes qui sont venus les aider pour
les épaules et qui sont carole baudon et
vanessa ternes à qui elles sont allés
travailler directement avec les hôpitaux
de jour en fait à la place que je peux
paraître il ya deux sortes entre
guillemets d'artistes qui ont travaillé
à cette exposition
donc vous charles-edouard de surville
eric lemaire qui avait créer vos oeuvres
en avec les enfants collectivement avec
les malades etc et les artistes qui le
head où je dis des bêtises et aide les
malades c'est vrai qu'elles n'avaient
pas forcément la même expérience me
elle était elle était plus présente
enfin physiquement fin elle était
physiquement présente aux ateliers se
dire qu'en fait elles les ont plus sa
compagnie dans le quotidien parce que
eric et charles-edouard est pas
forcément le temps et la disponibilité
pour aller à toutes les séances donc
l'an dernier oui carole et vanessa de
ternay cargo dont elles le font
régulièrement elle travaille
régulièrement avec vous déjà l'an déjà
fait et c'est vrai que c'est un vrai
travail de collaboration c'est à dire
c'est la rencontre de l'artiste avec ces
personnes souffrent et psychiquement et
hospitalisé en hôpital de jour
et c'est cette collaboration finalement
encadré grâce à madame boudon mêmes
ternay pour
voilà pourra finalement construire c est
vrai qu on se montrait que c'était aussi
on travaille pas à l'hôpital et que les
fêtes des dehors dans un lieu le fait de
ne s'était en fait ce projet c'est
vraiment une série d'expériences pour
aucune des oeuvres n'étaient garanties
d'arrivée ah oui et donc effectivement
dans parmi ces expériences il y avait
aussi toute la collaboration avec des
des personnes qui effectivement sont à
l'hôpital de jour mais pour lesquelles
on a travaillé soit dans le jardin soit
dans le studio
l'idée était vraiment d'arriver non pas
sur une un concept d'atelier finalement
d'expression artistique mais s'assure
collective exactement voilà justement on
va voir le résultat
on va commenter quelques-unes de vos
oeuvres vous que vous qualifiez
d'artistes sonore vous êtes intéressé
par enfin intéressés et inspiré
j'imagine par le sont par les phénomènes
de vibrations enfin la musique fait
partie intégrante le son la musique fait
partie des grands le point d'ancrage
c'est effectivement tout ce qui est
sonore
voilà d'autres voilà comment vous
l'appelez cette oeuvre s'appelle garden
party tu as des cas et en fait là ce qui
était vraiment passionnant dans le cadre
du jardin ces deux comme vous l'avez dit
d'avoir des oeuvres qui vont naître au
printemps et se terminer à des périodes
et de jouer avec le avec le vivant
d'accord elle est là en l'occurrence ce
sont des piédestaux sonore qui en fait
capte tous les sons du jardin et les
restitue de façon musicale
ouais de façon à donner une sorte de
contrepoint musicale à tout
l'environnement et tout le tout
l'ambiance sonore du jardin ok ensuite
nous avons cette oeuvre alors on voit ce
grammophon il y en a plusieurs
alors là effectivement l'idée c'était de
faire pousser des sortes de coquelicots
sonore à 10 et 30 ans et cosmos que l'on
appelle coquelicots à c'est vraiment
laide pourquoi alors c'est grave
enfin voilà c'est ça ce sont donc des
pavillons de gramophone dakar ont été
détournés et en fait qu'ils sont situés
très proche de 2 du monument aux morts
dans le jardin il ya eu toujours dit que
le risque c'est que la mémoire il y à un
monument aux morts cliquez à la fois
surprenant et qui assez imposant donc de
la guerre de 14-18 essentiellement
fidélité construit cette occasion là et
on a été surpris d'ailleurs en faisant
no no no no no promenade de
reconnaissance avec les hôpitaux de jour
de voir la distance en fait il se crée
entre les passants et ce monument aux
morts est réservé aux crocodiles
peut-être que c'est grammophon sont un
lien finalement pour que les gens se
seraient mes morts et excellent idée
c'était justement de voir comment on
pouvait créer un lien d'accord et genre
je suis de mauvaise nouvelle parce que
l'émission a presque terminé et on va
encore parler d'accord j'aimerais des
autres vauzelle pardon de vous presser
donc après on a alors celle là alors
celle là c'est c'est aussi c'est un jeu
en fait c'est faire jouer la fontaine
dans son jure de l'eau ils voient la cc
de transformer le son de la fontaine qui
ont musicalement on appelle à un bruit
blanc fait que dakar le son
caractéristique de tout de la mer et a
besoin de temps il ya tout le temps ce
jeu d'eau qui est effectivement là
qu'elle affronte n retombe sur les sur
la batterie et qu'elle ait créé des
déroulements de batterie d'analysés
jamais ni tout à fait les mêmes ni tout
à fait musique ni tout à fait ce bruit
d'accord et on va terminer par une autre
oeuvre qui qui est celle du piano ruche
comment vous l'appelez cette oeuvre
elle s'appelle musique coloniale où ils
n'ont rien à voir mais est donc vous
savez
installée oui colonisation la veille
vous avez donc installée de véritables
piano vous avez installé des essaims
d'abeilles et qui perdra si je me trompe
et après donc qu'elles se sont elles ont
donc coloniser ces pianos liv est
effectivement été de voir quel était
l'impact de entre 20 et 50 mille
abeilles dans dans deux pianos sur le
son qu'on pouvait faire sortir de ce
gratte de ce dispositif en l'abeille et
grâce effectivement à l'activité parce
que l'essentiel de l'activité d'une
ruche c'est de ventiler et de réguler la
température à l'intérieur de la ruche
donc elle bourdonnement un bourdonnement
incessant exactement et donc devoir en
fait qu'est ce qui allait se passer si
on a volontairement sous dimensionné
l'installation des abeilles pour leur
permettre de vraiment colonisé tout le
too late night ou d'abeille craquer ça
donne juste vraiment très envie c'est la
fin de l'émission merci d'avoir été
présent j'encourage donc les tout le
monde à aller voir cette exposition
notamment lors des journées du
patrimoine à qui approchent et vous
voulez dire un dernier mot laurence week
elle est gratuite que le talent est
gratuit
elle est où les gens dallas ma musique
tous les jours c'est un vrai travail de
co-création qu'on appelle toutes les
nuits merci vous votre travail à tous
les trois et écouter on va venir voir
cette magnifique exposition au plus vite
jusqu'au mois d'octobre merci d'avoir
été présent sur l'hers ici
il